la sueur enfin qu'il n'y a pas de
persécution religieuse ça me paraît
important j'ai discuté avec son code
peter pan de l'ong masayo non je
m'excuse non les îles dollars je
m'excuse ce n'est pas monsieur x man qui
m'empêchera de parler ici ce soir
j'étais en train de parler de
d'abstraction décembre les semble que
pour certains observateurs comme leroi
gourhan mais le progrès de la présente
un gros party qui s'est battu pendant
les dix la mersey s'est dit les écrans
l'humanité s'excuse je m'en vais bien
mais moi je ne reste pas avec voilà vous
êtes une femme
le débat n'est pas le méritait pas ça je
n'imaginais pas à quel point je suis
déçu aujourd'hui parfois ce casque est
dans la musique de bach ces quelques
siècles de paysannerie nous partions
semble vraiment dommage de tout ce temps
de jaurès on entendra enfin les réfugiés
naturellement que nous n'aurions pas sûr
si l'on reste sur la grille et vous
restez je ne reste pas en partie aux
individus ah ben voilà c'est la
démocratie
tout le monde aura à libérer la
démographie